تم إطلاق سراح 13 رهينة مدنية إسرائيلية أخرى
من أسر حماس كجزء من هذه
الصفقة بين إسرائيل وحماس والتي
أسفرت عن هدنة هشة بين
الطرفين المتحاربين، كنا في الواقع
نقف عند هذا التقاطع
كقافلة مع 12 من هؤلاء الرهائن الذين تم
إطلاق سراحهم حديثًا.  جاءوا مباشرة على
هذا الطريق في طريقهم إلى قاعدة هسيم الجوية،
لكن إحدى
الرهائن المحررين حديثًا تم
إجلاؤها طبيًا بطائرة هليكوبتر مباشرة من
قطاع غزة إلى مستشفى في جنوب
إسرائيل، اسمها إلما أبراهام وتبلغ من
العمر 84 عامًا وهي من سكان غزة.  المستشفى
الذي تعالج فيه يفيد بأنها
في حالة خطيرة قائلةً أن
حياتها في خطر الآن هذا أه ميد
هذا الإخلاء لقد حدث إطلاق سراح هؤلاء
الرهائن في الواقع بشكل مختلف
عن هاتين الليلتين الأخيرتين القادمين
مباشرة من قطاع غزة إلى إسرائيل
بدلاً من  المرور عبر معبر رفح
إلى مصر أولاً وقيل لنا
أن ذلك بسبب تلك
المشكلة الطبية الخطيرة أه مع إلما أبراهام الآن، سارت
العملية بخلاف ذلك
بسلاسة نسبيًا وشاهدنا
إطلاق سراح سريع إلى حد ما لهؤلاء الرهائن
ودخولهم مرة أخرى إلى إسرائيل  كان ذلك
تناقضًا كبيرًا مع ما رأيناه يوم
السبت في اليوم الثاني
لإطلاق سراح الرهائن حيث
تم تأجيل إطلاق سراح هؤلاء الرهائن لساعات من قبل حماس
بسبب خلافات حول
حجم المساعدات التي كانت إسرائيل تقدمها
لقطاع غزة وأيضًا  أعلم
أنه كان هناك نزاع خطير آخر
حول إطلاق سراح إحدى الرهائن
بدون والدتها، لقد
رأينا عادةً أه الأطفال والأمهات الذين تم
أخذهم كرهائن معًا يتم إطلاق سراحهم
معًا ولكن لم يكن هذا هو الحال مع
أحد هؤلاء الرهائن
والسؤال المطروح الآن هو ما إذا كان من
الممكن تمديد وقف القتال يوم السبت أم لا، وسواء كنا
سنشهد إطلاق سراح المزيد من الرهائن أم لا
من أجل تمديد هذا التوقف
في القتال، فسوف تحتاج حماس إلى إطلاق سراح
10 رهائن إسرائيليين آخرين يوميًا ليوم
إضافي من التوقف في القتال.  وقد
أشار المسؤولون الإسرائيليون المتقاتلون بالفعل
إلى أنهم يريدون تمديد هذه الهدنة،
ويريدون رؤية المزيد من إطلاق سراح الرهائن، وتقول
حماس يوم الأحد
في بيان لها إنها
تسعى أيضًا إلى تمديد هذه الهدنة لمعرفة مصير
أكثر من 180 رهينة بالإضافة إلى
مئات الشاحنات الأخرى التي تدخل
غزة معلقة في الميزان. جيريمي دايموند
سي إن إن أوريم
إسرائيل